[Applause]
[Music]
we're very excited today we have a bunch
of great artists from my heart comics
here we're playing a festival supreme
that debut of this IR Comics Super Show
on Saturday at the shrine and we're
gonna do something we've never done
which is a horrible mistake to do it the
first time with a thousand people here
before the best or the best exactly and
we're gonna do a crazy Team Coco /i hurt
comics death bracket which means we're
all gonna battle to see who's the best
video game player in the room and I
think you guys all know the answer I
think it's gonna be Frankie but we'll
see what so first up we got Frankie chan
Gavin Turek we're gonna be playing first
round we're gonna be playing a little
Mario Kart oh wait and in the back oh we
have the back cam there too the whole
time I love it we got Vanessa Michaels
and Mark Rudi Joe yes I did
so and they're they're gonna be up next
but first uh we're gonna have Frankie
and Gavin battle in a little Mario Kart
alright so have you guys ever played
Mario Cart before I played it on a Super
Nintendo
alright it hasn't changed a lot since
then
so here pick you're at first of all
let's we're gonna hold our thing like
this alright with this we move around
like this and then we select things like
this so Gavin you are blue so select
your person Frankie you're yellow right
I'm gonna find my blue card that's right
what's up keepo company I love this this
is this is the Internet in one comment
poop says lol that's it that's cu you've
done it you've encapsulated oh ah
Tanooki Mario Wow alright so hit hit a
when you got it right then I don't know
about this [ __ ] I just [ __ ] hit a a
bunch of times
that's right already that's right
two cameras hope you have double the
bandwidth Florence plugin that's not how
it works
we don't have extra cameras and extra
bandwidth all right now all this you
know I was gonna do this I guess we go
best at three all right all right and
you know what let's start let's start
you guys nice and easy nice and easy so
what all right so so a is gas B is brake
you don't use brake you want to go as
fast as possible if this is I think
slide you can slide around only in a bit
you lean a bit and for you yeah yeah for
you so this is this for you this is gas
and you turn by doing this okay all
right and and I think what is they
they're also you can use items I don't
remember what the buttons do you guys
will figure it out I think it's gonna be
yeah oh here we go
yeah yeah you got it
all right now while you guys are playing
I'm gonna go in the back and show the
bracket you guys play I'm gonna show
this crazy bracket
here's what we got this is a nightmare
start and turn to get poster board and
they did this sorry guys there we go
perfect so first we got play to keep
Gavin don't play me mark I'm currently
covering up no play Jacob what are you
see this on the thing then this will be
point wwk and then this will be a
justice
all right how we doing Oh Gavin killing
it I love it yeah I love it right shibby
says holy crap all right here we go you
know what though if neither one of you
guys know the tricks you're on the same
all right so you guys ready to answer
some questions let's do it Frankie so
you are the Creator by heart comma yes
it's been out for 11 years right not in
its current incarnation well oh my god
yeah that's great and how did it first
how'd you first what made you start I
are comics how did you first get the
impetus as I say well it's a slightly
complicated story but I moved to Los
Angeles in Seattle Washington at the end
2003 with the idea of making comic books
oh never did that cuz I couldn't find a
job but what I did know is how to throw
parties all right and I excite in
Seattle I ran a venue there so I started
a DJ party called [ __ ] awesome and
great name and a friend of mine named
never heard of him
never heard of Steve a big-ass DJ now
you're still in fifth you're doing great
Gavin you're doing great you're doing
great
Dimock yes yet Olivo called in mom if
you want to add all the parties and so I
had to come up with the name so it
didn't sound like Frankie Qian and vinh
moc so I know what the name I our comics
that's awesome but from there things
kind of took on a life of its own you
know like we went on its are throwing
other parties and I started a record
label and a website and and initially
did you find artists oh wow I let it be
fair you are talking how did you first
find artists just people who would play
at these parties
much you know because I've had such a
background in putting on that's great
that's insane
yeah I love it they were just and then
how did you how did you find Gavin Gavin
how did you become a part of our
accounts by the way great job thank you
high five right right in Frankie's face
and how did how did you and Gavin get
together well I met you first cuz you
were playing shows around town you
played some of our parties you played at
Chucky ponytail so I think that was it
was around that I think I saw you play
on your own before you play yeah Matt
and if you've never if you've never
heard Gavin's music it's amazing it's a
disco she's got a song right now come
front lines unbelievable time attribute
on a summer of it and by the way I've
seen you on Instagram dancing your
movies bananas it'll blow your socks off
and you're not wearing socks it'll ruin
your I don't know it'll mess you up it's
great though it's great I don't well
mushrooms have you get a mushroom you
can go faster beyond that that's great
and then and Gavin like how did you
start playing video games and talking is
like it's definitely ruined parts of my
fam oh my gosh so you you it's
I've always liked performing and just
being ridiculous in front of people ha
ha do you remember what was it what was
the first the very first time you
perform for someone like when you were a
kid you were ever I do and were you
nervous I you know I don't remember that
feeling honestly that's awesome I'm
always nervous now but when I was a kid
I just feel like I was so you're free I
was referring yeah my mom I remember
grabbing microphone for my mom and being
like I want to sing this song oh that's
awesome
she was like honey I'm on stage
performing like get off it I know right
it's my turn exactly exactly
oh yeah you keep so Frankie if you drift
so go faster if you drift by hitting the
this that and then you let it go if you
drift for a while and you let it go
you'll get a boost wait somebody here
that's a blur is dead-set I mean if you
can if you do the trigger this trigger
and then you let it go so you boost yeah
it's the triggers on the back you're
using the back right there right there
and that's for testing so if you always
love disco and you always love that kind
of music
yeah I just I love I mean I love all
kinds of music but I think the whole
that era and the fact that you know
we're just so beautiful and kind of like
with the big hair yeah oh my god you
look gorgeous today by the way you
brought it yes but a little class in the
Proceedings dql says I read comics
what's your flagship comic well look it
up what's your favorite comic what are
you reading right now well my favorite
comic right now might be either paper
girls or it's paper girls
David laughs ooh know who's doing paper
rips paper girls is Bryan combined oh
yeah
we have one more you eat your your tiny
one oh and thank you by the way tire all
right Hart comics for hosting us today
exactly you can check out Kevin's music
on round five everyone will hate each
other there's no round
we're not playing Mario Kart for the
whole time we're only playing for the
first time wait which one is the so this
is twitch this is YouTube all right so
you realize YouTube had a oh yeah gaming
oh yeah absolutely that's the wild west
the wild west over there let's see next
race last race guys here we go
but now Oh enjoy that's right use the
slide button I jump for extra boost
people are like getting upset I'm not
teaching them the proper way guys we're
going to sweet sweet Canyon great high
in calories right high and excitement
right exactly so what do you guys got
planned for the Super Show now you say
it's the debut of the Super Show and
right at a festival supreme you have
some special surprises planned or you
don't want to give it away for sure I
can give you like a little bit of a
the teaser all right give us a teaser
it's easiest way to describe it is a
little bit of like an r-rated Yo Gabba
Gabba
wow that's intense
I love it I've always wanted to see that
there's like oh there's like a little
story to it so it's kind of like the
Grinch that's still Halloween all right
I like it and you know it's stars except
I feel like the Grinch would be like
like a like a a shitty dad like a shitty
old white deck because the Grinch is a
monster so the Grinch himself wouldn't
steal hollowing cuz he'd be a Halloween
creature you know what I'm saying right
the opposite of a cool Halloween guys
like a dad he's like well we have a
character named death metal Sam oh my
god
that's like the big bad guy here and he
corrupts the brain of this child oh my
god
played by Ethan lessens Moya he's the
kid that TV show
roadies oh my gosh so he's you the star
and there's the whole cast of characters
which are B so of our land of icy
characters so there's a Anarchy Bunny
death Nana oh my cute little Lucifer and
all their minions holy Moses you guys
have this plane to a tee right and then
there is a obviously musical
performances throughout and are the
musical performances like is it gonna be
like who's Tommy are they like part of
the plot or not really yeah I mean there
it's like simultaneously soundtrack
choreographed to the music oh and the
storyline kind of like pushing the whole
thing grab performances by Marketo there
we go Gavin of course of course Kevin
chela with the special guest banoffee
Michael's with little place oh my gosh
that's crazy
good lord that's 2 hours long that's
gonna be insane it's amazing are you
guys taping this at all can you are you
gonna print on YouTube or anything like
that or you have to be there to see it
good question yeah I love it
lovely just build everything for it like
two days ago so it's gonna be a grand
experiment for everyone involved I love
that and Gavin's distracted by all the
sweets
oh those are so if you hitting this oh
you know what there you go press up on
the d-pad you'll throw up there you go
nice nice I should have told you that at
the beginning I'm doing the worst Gavin
who are you listening to right now oh
were some of your influences for your
for your new music are you high school
maybe don't exactly but his new [ __ ] I'm
really into DJ's honey dijon
okay again I'm losing because I'm
distracted sorry I know but I want to
ask you questions but I don't want to
make you wish I'm Gavin it's terrible
I'm dwelling yeah I'm sorry you know
what that's my fault
that's my father I'm sorry David I'm
sorry I'm so sorry
well Frankie advances sorry Gavin you
know what here's the great prize
that's right all right you get a prize
don't look so we get it we have this
thing at work called the free bin where
people send us stuff and we just throw
in the free bin and it's all kinds of
random stuff it's all fancy companies
and and authors and all these other
people so there's stuff in here now it's
random out there grab something out of
it yep there's a lot of weird stuff all
right oh you got what did you get dogs
and their people dogs and their people
there we go look at this wonderful this
has such gems in it is this dog and
their person or perhaps this dog I think
they're laying on someone's pant leg or
something so I guess that counts as
having a person and oh look at this
Gavin look at this you think this is
amazing we can use this to maybe just
before you go onstage is a little I
don't know yeah cut - cut - it looks
like the album cover of that rap artist
DRAM yes on the show I think some are oh
it's like Hammond is puppy it's the
cutest there yeah this is when Gavin's
music turn to street dogs and cue
costumes all right so Frank you're gonna
move over here with me okay and then all
right Vanessa mark let's go
get over here get over here we're gonna
get nice and friendly all right
but Nestle Michaels everybody markridge
IDO that's right with an e with an A you
get exactly exactly
welcome guys oh Jesus just trying I was
trying to say she came in earlier and
gave me a handshake like this no I
it's like Oswald Cobblepot copperpot
which I guys do what Stan give me in his
name is the penguin copper 5 that's
that's what it is
you weren't getting com2 um but yeah
like this you should try and shake my
hand like this which is I don't I don't
do the claw I don't do the Keyser söze I
go straight in like that's right and
nice I'm nice and sweaty which is how
you shake a girl's hand no no I'm doing
this now do you tink okay this is and
high-fives are so violent these days
just like a nice soft little tingle
welcome guys uh you guys are performing
obviously see the super show I heard
comics festival supreme it's gonna be
amazing
I just yeah don't don't
that's it with an E everybody Vanessa
quit in here that's what you wanted and
some Michaels that's right alright hey
if you would perfect all right and now
you hold it like this you might be so
kind and then could select your guy Marc
you're blue okay you're yellow all right
let's see the winner of this will play
Frankie I know the winner of this will
play I love it I'm gonna choose Devin
how you doing back there
I love it what you got on that we just
got talk [ __ ] on the right yeah you know
what talk [ __ ] on us over here exactly
I'll come back there and visit you don't
worry all right I don't know what this
stuff is I just hit a button but you
know what if you wanna make a car look
quiet you know I wish I had spent more
time on this I thought would add a
faster car that's right exactly finally
Sabet actions is Andy all right let's
get creepy yeah there we go Internet hey
it's Beth oh man people are freaking out
about Beth
that's right all right I'll just hit a
hit and then oh you know what
well have you guys are you guys wearing
fans all right well let's fix it we need
mark you it's been a minute to say last
place it's been a minute that's okay
let's go a little bit let's go a little
crazy let's go uh flower you like a
flower I was like a deer plate plate
terrible
well circuit man let's get a little nuts
I like Kate to you what's that
yeah read this at your own risk oh you
guys are awesome there you go thanks
Tori thanks Tori someone tweeted at us
Team Coco stream Coco to the random
porno title generators 69,000 to come up
with that or that just toilet humor
stream Coco yeah I don't know I just
want an acid front of team get your mind
out of the game
I think you guys are giving me too much
credit I was like let's see we're
live-streaming our name is team Coco you
smash them together you get stream Coco
it's that easy
oh no oh [ __ ] oh good lord
oh they're hard okay there you go there
you got it sorry all right and also the
trigger in the back is you drift if you
want to use that I am you press up for
you Vanessa drifting is this back here
and I'll you're gay yeah what am I even
explaining yeah oh this is just like
that she's in the zone
she's in the zone she's learning I wait
mark you're I was reading up when you
guys your former name is spaz kid yep no
they seem pretty chill for spaz County
climate we've got
is that kind of the job yeah yeah yeah I
have a calm down his old age
oh really Wow very rocks as Mountain Dew
Code Red
yep yep exactly or was it Crystal Pepsi
I don't know
there we go and what are you from my
lair where'd you grow up I grew up in
the Philippines in Manila oh my god
that's awesome now what kind of music
did you listen to growing up I listened
to a lot of punk rock there we go what
screeching weasel or do we talking to
him dude I'm like Bad Religion there are
stuff like that oh yeah Operation Ivy
operation I hate it yeah black you got
your black flag black flag minor threats
yep I used to have a green mohawk you
can imagine me wait how high I was like
I would you have to sleep on like your
set aside like to be able to was it like
one of these giant like rancid it's like
2-3 inches it's not that hard
what kind of maintenance goes into a
mohawk not a lot bro I would usually
wear glue instead of gel and that keeps
my hair and lightweight like glue like
literal glue like straight-up like
Elmer's glue the calibers Achilles cool
white bottle with the orange basically
what the [ __ ]
Gel doesn't work with that yeah I use
eggs what's going on you're basically
baking a cake on your head every day
okay I just so many questions my first
one is did birds try to eat your head
all the time cuz it's like delicious
you're basically talking about all you
need to put it's like I don't know like
like cooking chocolate in there and you
have way Browns yeah sure and they would
have been tasty also did you Wow well
done oh my god this is just a bunny you
gotta fit it come on
I've given up great I've never seen
someone collapse so quickly no you have
another chance it's best to three okay
okay okay I can't wait to see mark and
Gavin play chess oh I know the weight
and how did you when you go to sleep
do you have spikes in the back your head
yeah how did you how did you live your
life like did you could you walk through
the doorway
wow that's crazy that's you that's all
you have all you have is time and you're
16
oh my god I'm gonna start asking Vanessa
questions so then she's a little
distracted okay are you ready yeah how
many Mohawks have you had don't you
should definitely not try yeah no thanks
this is a wig comes right off I've had
gray hair since I was 14 silverfox41 the
great goes coming at you it's actually
but I guess I could buy beer early
actually I couldn't decide to babyface
cuz I couldn't grow up here it was I was
cursed with everything yeah you know
what doesn't go well in high school of a
newt gingrich look like a fat
gray-haired thanks somali appreciate
that i looked like as cool as gavin
looks right now that's how uncool i
looked that was the opposite coin of
Gavin have I ever had hot dogs yes I
have it was a great question delicious I
actually had some sausages down on
Saturday and then I went to a video game
bar because that's my life thinking
buyers now are the thing save it from
urine no no it's mirror they're fun
right
oh my god I had a great time you guys
there we go that like 82 downtown oh
yeah yeah super fun although I get crazy
intimidated because people they're like
I got anything oh wow oh you're watching
us it's like Inception only only a way
louder and more obnoxious because I'm
screaming that's great now Vanessa now
you I do a lot of remixes you're a how
would you describe your so how would you
describe your sound um
I am super like influence of the
nineties Color Me badd I'm guessing
alright okay perfect
I mean but then also there's like
another side of me looks like all about
no doubt and like sublime I feel like
that's the same side yeah all that stuff
is great nineties music yeah that's just
one awesome great side yeah so I
actually have that I call 20 90s so it's
like 90 or like Justin it's called
what's it called 29 29 yeah you know
there's a comic book called like
universe and Marvel called 2099 oh yeah
wait a minute we 99 and 0:29 oh that's
great close like all walls in the future
you're very close to it a terrible
series of comic books that's way more
disappointing that it was exciting a
research right now is it really
comic even ravage 2099 is back I don't
of you know that one ravage know where
sound like a carnage and gravich was the
original new character by Stan lien that
he made for the 399 launch in the 90s we
shoe is a character made out of trash
he's a garbage man that got super power
they've made me new become of a
character everybody crash it's done
they've done it somehow they've done it
no malice someone thought that was a
good day 2099 did promise a lot of stuff
voting live I keep leaving they were
like we [ __ ] it up one let's do it
again oh my god wow my god one mark I'm
so sorry I also did like the t1000 Mario
like the liquid metal hooks in a hand
yeah rampage is a literal trash
character that's true I didn't know you
could do that I don't I think we've
unlocked a bunch of alright well mark
why is he doing that enough there you go
you get to reach into our bag of
slightly above trash don't look though
don't why I don't go by feel go by feel
okay there might be some mashed potatoes
and they're gonna ignore them I think
it's time brains it's Halloween don't
worry about it alright
Oh what do we got what do we got I Oh
rock and roll road trip with Sammy Hagar
oh yeah DVD of a rock and roll road trip
and braking and also Breaking Bad
Breaking Bad
Michonne
yeah here's some rock legends of the
merging musicians all right you gets
here at Dave Navarro's your mobis
Sebastian Bach whoa okay hell yeah
Bastian Bach there you go well there's
your country surprise word won't be much
consolation where you go mark indeed
everybody all right so now I think we're
gonna have you know I gotta go look at
the board real quick hold on a second to
please me
let's see Oh Frankie you and I play Oh
we're gonna play here's our giant
reformed game uh yeah we're gonna play
WWE 2k all right then all right get
Frankie you know I love my mark around
me but we play and then Vanessa's could
play Jacob Oh Jacob
all right here we go
all right today all right mark you want
to retire to look at gallery all right
now let's see I'm gonna switch it up
all right
aren't you guys are just joining us we
are here with Frankie Chan Gavin Turek
Vanessa Michaels and Marc or Dido from I
heart comics they are playing this
Saturday at the shrine that did they
debut of their super show the iron
comics super have estable supreme best
of a supreme baby it's gonna be amazing
they've got death metal Santa Claus it's
a whole story it's gonna be it's gonna
blow your mind right out of your brain
pan
oh no that's I don't know this is gonna
be fun one on one we go let's just go
normal you know yeah not no Extreme
Rules
no Extreme Rules I don't face a
different system oh yeah oh we're on it
now let's see here
all right this is you know I'll be this
guy and you be alright here we go
we've actually had Roman reigns on
stream Coco which is fun and we played
this game and he destroyed me shockingly
enough now you are Uwe fan or no because
I don't know anything about wrestling me
neither but I knew I do know a lot about
body those guys got a great look okay
[Laughter]
I'm gonna go this guy Rey Mysterio
because the ultimate warrior not dude
look at those faint faint
oh here you know what hit ex Bowden life
since I haven't played WWE games it's
the early 2000s dude you got to get
going though Randy Orton or get the [ __ ]
out shocking so yeah so if I are comics
you've got to be you've got to be happy
I mean this is a huge success that's
good it's getting there it's good where
would you like to see our heart comics
go
besides world domination which I know is
I could see in your that's the easy
answer exactly
well ideally we end up being somewhere
we end up being a media company
somewhere and
realm of like a Marvel or Adult Swim
cool where we have a lot of our own
characters and universities media
properties that's awesome you know maybe
it's someone with more similar structure
device oh there we go
absolutely in terms of like but not some
news base more creativity and yeah and
like weird shed base did you see the I
love the Action Bronson watching ancient
aliens did you see that yeah oh my god
we actually just did Comic Con with
Iceland oh wow yeah and we had Action
Bronson on this party bus that that
bison made where where we actually just
showed that TV show on repeat I love it
while people smoke weed of course as you
do yeah dude
[Applause]
the graphics mark what's your favorite
wrestling character there we go hello
there I'm plan
hey Vanessa what's your favorite
wrestling character just make up a name
make up a name Gavin's back hey Gavin
what's your favorite wrestling character
[Applause]
just make up a name what do you guys
know jake the snake' absolutely all
right I don't know how to play this so
let's just see what we got I think this
is just gonna be a lot of button mashing
which is what it is look at that hair
come on
oh there we go how do I get out there to
kid you already broke my arm brother I
get out there you know what here's what
bothers me I wouldn't want to have the
lane I'm not sure I think you're just
doing poses we try coming back in try
pushing up okay you know I think use
this use the stick let me know whether
stay there there we go
you tried up an ax or maybe up in a
trigger here let's try let's we we
discovering the flaw in the game it's
impossible to get back in okay yeah oh
here we go oh there we go
all right let's trade back okay back oh
oh God whoever's doing are you are you
doing the iron comics whose dude oh
that's great
I look Jacob is just like [ __ ] on us
from right over here that's my favorite
thing he's ever voting for just kidding
Oh God oh not out to the ring again get
back in the ring how do I get back in Oh
oh my god this is bad that sucks
doors why do they make wrestling games
so complicated this is like the dumbest
thing ever punch you right in the face
oh I just hit axe and he did that Oh
oh god oh god oh god wait let's go back
back to this go back to this round 2
round 2 is a mess you know what we might
just go back don't restart it there we
go perfect I feel like we should just
boot this and playing justice
should we just screw this game what's
injustice it justice is just superheroes
punching each other yeah yeah let's do
that
forget this last year rounds were gonna
do it justice I'm pulling a pulling
inaudible
on something that was completely
unplanned all right perfect
oh she's doing that what is that you got
your are you and Jim are you in Jim Jim
I'm flip-flopping and this is a great
new thanks guys flip-flapping Jim Jim
that's right Jim
now being a comic book fan Superman vs
Batman dawn of Justice thoughts let's
hear the extended version is better why
because they actually explain a lot of
the stuff that they didn't try and
explain but it doesn't make it a good
movie it doesn't make make them makes
more sneaking around over here it
doesn't make them like that anymore
compelling you're right you're right not
dang liens fault but I agree with you no
but just the whole like then I'll be
Batman baby
and let's play and you will Arkham
Asylum all right so best is gonna be
best of three right all right all right
look like there's a lot of logic flaws
and in that films yes it's a lot of just
punching in the rain and not a lot of
like talking hey O'Malley can you
uncover the other chat for me thank you
look at me just coming out of bats we
change the game because the wrestling
game sucks so now we're playing
injustice it'll be great he'll be great
Gavin favorite superhero character go oh
come on don't be so obvious all right oh
oh
there we go come on Oh Oh would you meet
me with a canister or something
it doesn't seem right now I think when
you're when your thing gets all the way
back I'm Batman currently getting my
butt kicked I think when you guide us
watching us
yeah it's like thinking my shop right
now you could do a thing where when your
thing gets full I think if you hit both
triggers you'll do like a special
I love Joker's posture like this here we
go it is a special thing
to see when your thing will never do
that
that's true you're ready this is a
different Batman this is a dark this is
a dark night you know this is like a a
flick I'm gonna burn you in the face
all right so hey both your triggers hit
both your triggers let me get close then
hit with your ears with me oh oh wait
don't do this do this both these time oh
oh that seems unfair oh that's awesome
actually here takes himself soft fabric
into the face oh damn it that's me
that's me sorry that's me
I have no coordination which is why I
win two video games for a living
no you're destroying me dude why do I
keep shooting the dumb thing oh geez oh
oh all right you got one that smile I
know I feel like Joker's a guy doesn't
brush his teeth you know he's a rebel
huh
yeah for sure he's like let's buy a
turkey ha ha brush his teeth look
pudding yeah wait is that's how I brush
my teeth I like what the tapioca balls
get right in there you know ah rematch
here we go ready yeah let's do it
here our hit ax
whoo now I've hired comics what's what's
your roster I mean people you got on
your roster on the label on the way up
right now there's a war and do you think
like eventually you'll get to a place
where it's dozens and dozens or do you
like to keep it tight so you kind of
well this you give everybody their
proper do this version of the label is
more of an experiment so it's not a
proper label in the sense of like for
signing people for like pulling records
and doing all that stuff
it is a singles label where the focus is
actually on the music videos oh that's
off and with the videos we've been
creating our own shared universe oh my
god oh
everything takes place in one macro
story was like the Justice League for
now exactly oh so but very much using
like the template of like you know the
Marvel Cinematic Universe yeah to create
bonds there's no superheroes in art but
there is a big story and and that's kind
of why this is part of the fun yeah the
Super Show oh my god the Super Show this
weekend I I see now he kind of all is
coming together like it's kind of its
kind of a mythology that you guys are
creating right you know and the Super
Show does star the land of it--see
characters which are more of like our
cartoon character and stuff whereas the
infinity world is definitely more
cinematic like it stars like an actual
actors and actually effects and stuff
that's all so that's its its own like
sub universe but the Super Show mixes
both in a way in the sense that the
artists are performing but but it's not
based around that it's not based around
the Infinity demint mythology yeah right
that's really cool and where did you get
the idea for that just because there's
from comics no [ __ ] nerd yeah dude I
love that Oh gotcha
ah the worst son of a [ __ ] nice job
and he's so apathetic
I feel like Joker's gotta like really a
stretch before he fights things y-yeah
then he's [ __ ] up when he advice
because he doesn't give a [ __ ] that's
you you're right guy watching us you
know I bet that to go strange
he's like a science mad scientist
villain right I've no fear lead isn't
well done Bob son he's just like this
he's got a sweet beard though alright
vanessi you're up I got killed is
running against her ah no it's gonna be
Jacob versus Vanessa you got to get on
in jegan here we go you're all ready now
look I sweat a lot so this is gonna be a
sweaty controller I'll show you it's
really actually have no idea which is
gonna be fun all right we're gonna go
new fighters
this is you here see a select your
character
Jacob everybody welcome Jacob I love it
alright so you're - you're - oh yeah hot
girl does that girl have real wings
because that would be awkward on a date
you know like I'm saying like you gotta
hold the door open and then the wings
and kind of hit you in the face
oh you guys got a pic where you want to
kick the crap out of each other yeah
yeah there we go
wonder was in this game by the way how
awesome is that Wonder Woman trailer oh
my god it's the best it is the best that
person know you'd probably waves no no
okay hot girl does have wings cavities
are he's hot girl oh my god we got a
little moral combat here what room is
not even touching the ground
wait what we can't fly since why can't
why holy Sh Jacob's gonna bananas you've
got rope you've got a shield a sword
how good when I fight I wouldn't want
anything over my mouth you know like you
don't want anything I'm gonna be able to
breathe okay right and how do you
trashed all over my yeah exactly like
how do you trash talk with like
something like any oh my god also so
when you're when you're when you're you
guys can if you're you can hit both
triggers Wonder Woman and you'll do a
special crazy beat Oh hit both backdrops
oh there we go that's what it is oh nice
oh you got your minions now Jacob you
can do that too you can do that too it's
when you're you gotta get close to her
though it's when you're when you're a
bar you're gonna see that opportunity do
it to do it oh I think she's down though
you mr. battle back up just feeling your
oats there it is lovely people get like
a pail that it's like oh I've no idea
what's happening
people get impaled and it's just like
yeah I'm still fighting
Oh Jacobs not dead Jacobs on Ted well
done first round
that's that's definitely gonna leave a
mark
you did want you're gonna want to get
some neosporin on that that's that's
pretty real levelled up great job are
there is there anybody from Austria or
Germany in the Chad nobody knows no GL
in the new Justice League yeah you know
what Green Lanterns too powerful he's
that he's a space sighs a space
policeman you know that's basically its
deal here I hit export
how can you play two player call of duty
just people just yeah this is Hugh man
Jacob this is all you this round belongs
to you hey yeah O'Malley can you push
the views down to the bottom that
windows down to the bottom Thank You
Lauren yeah lower left all right
uh Tori asked am I gonna be Catwoman for
Halloween not this year
I'm actually gonna go we're gonna be in
Halle we're gonna be in New York
following so I'm going to take my old
standby my Jar Jar Binks mask and I will
be dressing up like George yeah do let's
go as twin Jar Jar Binks know what I
should do maybe I should get a bunch of
them in like like staple them all over
me like I've murdered a bunch of Jar Jar
Binks like at Jar Jar Binks like Silence
of the Lambs or something are you guys
Halloween people were you guys to ask
for how much I never let the inspiration
strike you Jacob I never know and I'm
gonna be into like the day of what did
you guys last year do you love it oh I'd
crush these if I didn't need them oh
that's a long time all right Jacob
you know you you've seen everyone else
get a consolation prize now it's time
for you get in there get in there oh
Jesus there's a big bag of something
nice oh you got a Korea snack I don't
know what this is but it's got a
saluting squid on it so it's probably
some kind of squid you're gonna be
eating this guy right there I'm sorry
how excited are you
it's gonna be great also I think there's
instructions on how to eat it on the
back I'm not sure what's going on in the
back there I gotta say Korea you are a
beautiful people I love you amazing all
right so now I think it's let's see wait
I got it let me go check out the bracket
sorry oh you did not right right yeah
all right yeah yeah I think we got
so I lost Frankie Frankie moves I like
this and that's so it's just been
murdering everybody sorry I know this is
boring sorry everybody
I'll be right there God buh all right so
now here's what we got sorry guys
alright can you I don't think even see
what's going on it all right so I lost
Frankie advances and this says Vanessa
you can't really tell it's just now it's
Vanessa Frankie also I think since
Frankie is the head of IR comics if you
lose I think you're fired
sorry as an artist you're fired I forgot
to everybody's agreed to these terms so
I forgot to tell you that before we
started all right the best thing to is
we can't see you can't we can't see
Gavin here it's like a thing so it's
just like a voice like you got this you
got this girl exactly you can do it
she's your obi-wan
she's your obi-wan all right so hit acts
there if you would sir
are you're going Wonderwoman again of
course all right
and I said this again this will be loyal
yeah you're like well you know what she
served you well so far you know she's
the lady you came in with yeah team
Vanessa Team Jacob Jacob lot sorry
now let's see it's team Frankie and
Frankie with a knock Frankie man that
it's all it's just tea my heart comics I
say where you guys gonna play let's find
the fortress of solitude no there we go
of the to the right to the right this is
you this is you yeah where's your
solitude it's gonna get cold
you don't I'm saying with just something
I brought on The Ultimate Fighter to go
against Wonder Woman there we go Peter
Kern says your jacket and topper lit wow
I think that's a good thing that's right
it's like Jacob study exactly time for a
bomb rip Seth that's right everybody
taking his bumper Oh
Deathstroke here's what I don't get
about Deathstroke yeah what not to
distract you but he doesn't any depth
perception
oh is he's only got one eye Slade Wilson
by the way amazing tactician but he's
also the most skilled fighter and that's
true that's true although currently
losing to Wonder Woman
I love Tuesday in the back there yeah
why is the team potato we do see the
combo in real-time lays hail Santa
that's right skulls copy got his ticket
oak whoa whoa I think he just like truth
or dare - we were like you're like what
are you scared of it's like bunnies he
punched
that's right oh here we go
oh it's on oh no oh that's bad oh oh oh
in the face Oh aggressive is extremely
aggressive crazy when you're when you're
helping here goes all the way up you can
do the same thing well not be exactly
boys just got guns man that's crazy but
why is he just using our here you can do
the triggers now got swords you get a
sword fighting wow that was crazy
[Music]
alright do you want to switch up your
characters or not you you want to stick
with Deathstroke I'm just figuring him
out so alright we're gonna go in alright
rematch rematch hit accidentally hit axe
there we go this is it dude this if you
lose this is she's the champion right
all right we have a suite by the way a
prize for the champion I'm just gonna
put out there it's not in the box of
free stuff although I did get it also
that's right now Fletcher I can see
everything including what you're wearing
and you look great today
those pants really bring out your eyes
damn girl can't fight that's right Andy
geez just killing it this is my move oh
oh oh oh my god as if you played this
before natural yeah I'm look at your
hands you're just hitting one button so
yeah just one button you just hit square
she's just sitting square he's just
hitting square just hit square bunch
sorry I dragged you up oh oh I don't
know what this is the wager thing
Doomsday's panting awfully hard is he
gonna be okay I think he's getting I
think Jews day really has to go to the
bathroom he's doing the peepee dance to
the back he's having a stroke back there
oh no there we go
yeah button match for the win yes he'll
gamer of course I love you
good lord what kind of questions oh this
is that's bad for you you're gonna get
shot the face again I know you're on
your last legs Frank come on this no no
no oh god oh no oh no don't sign into
PlayStation Network go back on Frankie
go back your Lear it
there was some that was some that was
very stressful that was a very stressful
[ __ ] Wow oh my god well done well done
well done well done well done
all right Frankie take a consolation
prize Vaness is the champion
Frankie trying to cheat oh you got a
power lets you know for everyone else we
got a prize for everyone else here too
so we'll give everyone else another
prize
oh wait power greens cookbook I'm
guessing this is just all how to make
kale taste delicious and this is how
many pages it took them to figure that
out as kales ridiculous all right you
get it as a consolation prize Parents
magazine Frankie or Gavin let's see you
want to IMAX little monster shirt oh
sorry
mark and more common oh yeah how about a
rats I don't know what this is it's a
film about rats
it just says rats a film by Morgan
Spurlock oh so maybe he eats like three
you might get 30 rats in 30 days I don't
know who knows and then Jacob here you
go you get a vote ray Donovan pinch
right and for Vanessa our champion she
gets us something else I got out of the
out of the free Ben it's a it's a
traditional Korean wedding march from
Korea and it's got little little dudes
in their little little people there you
go and it's got a nice little thingy you
could probably wear this around your
neck you know I say little Flavor Flav
yeah exactly that's a new thing
oh my goodness well thank you to all the
amazing people my heart comics thank you
jack that's and Michaels margarita and
Gavin Couric and please go see on the
debut of their super show the I heart
comics Super Show Festival supreme this
Saturday at the shrine follow all these
guys at Frankie chat at Vanessa Michaels
with an e with an e at Gavit Uruk and at
marker dido and go to ir comics comm for
all their amazing music and anything
you'd like to add mr. Dubbs
that's it it's gonna be amazing
the festival supreme get your tickets
are going fast and come in costume and
it's gonna be an amazing crazy show
it'll gone for death-metal Santa Claus
right be incredible alright thank you
guys and we'll see you next week scream
duck
you